[Music]
the marathon
one of the greatest feats of strength
and endurance in the world
some runners prepare for months maybe
even years
but for today's challenge we're going to
complete a marathon without any training
what kind of effects would it have on
your body
well on today's episode we're going to
find out
this is your body on running a marathon
without training
it's common knowledge that a marathon is
42 kilometers long
but have you ever heard of an ultra
marathon
these are races where people run
anywhere between 50 to 5 000 kilometers
some races take place over several days
nearly 50
of the competition failed to complete
but the rest do
end up crossing the finish line so if
these people can run hundreds of
kilometers
surely you can run a measly 42k right
right okay
let's get off the couch and do this
thing and see what's happening inside
your body as you run
kilometer one your body shouldn't have a
hard time handling this at the start
even without training you should be able
to complete this distance within 10
minutes
and as you continue your lungs will
start to expand more rapidly
you'll also feel the need to breathe
with just your mouth rather than your
nose
this allows your body to pull in more
oxygen and at a much quicker pace
kilometer five so by now you've been
running for at least half an hour
if you're not used to physical activity
this would probably be the point where
you'd end your attempt
but that's not really our style on your
body on
we finish our challenges no matter how
hard they might be
so get moving as you continue running
your marathon you'll notice your body
feeling much hotter
let's take a closer look at the
beginning of the race your core body
temperature was around 37 degrees
celsius
now if you're not used to running your
temperature will rise to 39.4 degrees
celsius
this might not sound that bad but it's
the equivalent of a high fever
and the higher your core temperature is
the more difficult it is for your heart
to pump blood out to your muscles
do you think you'll be able to make it
to the end let's keep going to find out
kilometer 15 you're now about two hours
into the marathon
you're incredibly exhausted but the good
news your body is burning an insane
amount of calories
at the start of your run your body was
burning about 150 calories every hour
but now your body is burning nearly 800
calories per hour
that means you can eat a big mac in a
small order of fries
and within an hour burn the entire meal
off
kilometer 33 okay
now your run is becoming more difficult
than ever before
you've hit what's known as the wall
this happens after your body has burned
its entire supply of glucose
glucose is stored in your muscles and
liver and is your primary source of
energy during your run
normally experienced runners will start
their marathon off slow to avoid this
part of the race
but you came bursting out of the gate
and now your glucose is expended
and it's harder than ever to keep
running your muscles now need more to
help operate
and as a result you're feeling more
sluggish than ever
kilometer 42 by this point you're at
least six
hours into this terrible idea an
experienced runner would be finishing
the race with
shin splints stress fractures and other
muscle injuries
but for you the muscle tears would be
even worse
you also have an increased amount of
lactating your leg muscles which will
lead to cramps
at this point you'll be lucky if you can
crawl to the finish line
but your leg pain wouldn't even be the
worst part of all this
your kidneys would suffer even more a
2015 study
found that 82 percent of runners had
stage one acute kidney injury
immediately following a marathon these
injuries happen when your kidneys aren't
getting enough blood flow
they're also due to dehydration during
this time your kidneys aren't able to
filter toxins out of your blood
so yes in theory you could finish this
marathon without any training but you'd
probably end up bruised and beaten
and possibly in a hospital bed
yeah this is a challenge you don't want
to try
if you want to run a marathon safely
here's some advice
coaches say that you should run a total
of at least 48 kilometers a week for
five to six weeks
and you should be able to do this
comfortably if you want a real shot at
this race
remember to stretch as much as you can
to stay hydrated
and to walk when you're feeling weak
this will help you finish the race
without any serious injuries
follow this advice so you can kill this
challenge instead of having it kill you
so that's your deep dive into running a
marathon without training and it's
tough to recommend what about another
test of your body
like eating mcdonald's for a year
straight
we'll see what that challenge brings on
the next episode
of your body on